foreign
psychological level dreaming I mean it's
pretty ridiculous when you think about
it because last night you and I when we
went to sleep and we started dreaming we
became completely psychotic
and before you reject that sort of
diagnosis of my nighttime psychosis I'll
give you five good reasons when we dream
we start to see things which are not
there so you're hallucinating
you also believe things that couldn't
possibly be true so you're delusional
you get very confused about time and
place and sometimes also person as well
so you're suffering from disorientation
you often have these wildly
pendulum-like almost fluctuations in
your emotions and it's what
psychiatrists will call being
effectively labial or emotionally labile
and then how great you and I both woke
up this morning and we forgot most if
not all of that dream experience so
we're suffering from amnesia
and if you you know if you were to
experience any one of those five things
while you're awake you probably would be
seeking some form of psychiatric
intervention but for reasons that we're
now only starting to understand when it
comes to the functions of dreaming it's
a perfectly normal biological and
psychological process
the biological process is utterly
interesting we and others have done
studies where we've been putting people
inside of brain scanners and we let them
go through the different stages of sleep
and we let them go into REM sleep now
dreaming if you use a loose definition
which is with the report of any mental
activity upon Awakening if you use that
loose definition you dream in almost
every stage of sleep but what most
people think of when you say Dreaming or
REM sleep dreams those are the emotional
The Narrative the bizarre the strange
that's really the state from which you
dream and when we look at that sleep
stage inside of the MRI scanner firstly
vast swaths of the visual cortex start
lighting up in your brain the motor
regions of the brain erupt in activity
emotional centers of the brain become
active as well as memory centers of the
brain and in fact some parts of your
brain are up to 30 more active when
you're in dream sleep than when you're
awake which is stunning to me because we
often think of sleep as just this
passive non-conscious state
metabolically from the brain perspective
it's wild
but the freakish part is what happens to
another region of your brain called the
prefrontal cortex and particularly the
left and the right side which sits just
above your eyes
and it's particularly a region called
the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex left
and right side of the frontal lobe that
part of the brain normally when it's
active acts like the CEO of the brain
that it makes high level sort of
executive top-down control decisions and
it allows you to have not just rational
decisions but volitional decisions in
other words you're choosing to make that
choice and you're choosing to do that
action that's part of the prefrontal
cortex job
that part of the brain goes offline when
we go into REM sleep your dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex doesn't erupt with
activity like many of these other
regions it is suppressed in its activity
and that I think is our current
explanation as to why your dreams are so
visual so motoric filled with past
memories them
also just highly emotional but they're
utterly bizarre utterly erratic and you
have no volitional control the prison
guards have left the building and the
prisoners are running a mark your
prefrontal cortex is down and so that's
one of the fascinating parts of dream
sleep neurologically as well as the body
by the way
I think we probably didn't discuss this
before but when you go into dream sleep
your brain paralyzes your body
you are completely limp so if I were to
come into the to the bedroom and just
pick you up during REM sleep you would
be like a rag doll all of your skeletal
muscles are inhibited
and people don't need to worry by the
way your involuntary skeletal muscles
that control your respiration in your
heart they're not affected but all of
your voluntary muscles are because your
brain stem which is where the REM and
non-rem mechanisms play out
not only does it beam an activating
signal up into the dreaming brain it
sends one down the spinal cord and it
paralyzes what's called the Alpha motor
neurons of the spinal cord that control
your voluntary skeletal muscles so you
are locked into a physical incarceration
during REM sleep during dream sleep
which by the way explains something
called REM sleep paralysis upon
Awakening and adequately explains most
alien abductions but we don't need to go
though